also in New Hampshire was not only Ron
Des Sanctus but it was also Donald Trump
in New Hampshire Trump gave a speech
which we will look at but I don't
remember if this was before or after the
speech Donald Trump was confronted about
the leaked crime tape now I don't even
know that we should call it a leaked
audio tape it's a leaked crime tape in
which Trump confirms yeah he knew the
documents were classified he knew he
didn't declassify them he knew he was no
longer the president and he still showed
them to people it is evidence of Trump's
crimes and it is not vaguely of Trump's
crimes he might be charged with
it's evidence of Trump's crimes that he
has already been charged with and and
indicted for Trump is asked about the
leaked audio tape and he says honestly I
don't even know how to explain what he
says he just basically malfunctions here
and says I did nothing wrong
we did absolutely nothing wrong this is
just another hoax it's called Uh I would
say election interference more than
anything else it's a disgrace that they
can do it next question but everything
was fine we did nothing wrong and
everybody knows it
a sample of that newly released audio
from two years ago
I was just saying because we're talking
about it and you know he said he wanted
to attack Iran
this was done by the military given to
me
um I think we can probably think
yeah last week with our colleague Brett
Baer the former president insisted that
document did not exist
there was no document that was a massive
amount of papers and everything else
talking about Iran and other things and
it may have been held up or may not but
that was not a document I didn't have a
document per se okay it wasn't a
document per se so listen that's Fox
News first of all notable that even Fox
News now they realize that it is an
incoherent string of lies that conflict
with each other he says to Brett Baylor
there were no documents in the recording
he says here's documents then he says it
was fine to show the documents but
because I could declassify them but in
the recording he says they clearly
weren't uh you know it's it's it's all a
mess and Trump's brain seems to be
functioning so poorly that he's lost an
understanding of what words even mean at
this point what does hoax mean at this
point and what what does it mean that it
is a hoax there is a an audio recording
is he saying it's doctored is he saying
the words he uses in the video no longer
have meaning and of course if you just
sit back and think about all of the
conflicting things that have been said
you start to wonder listen don't you
understand guys the tape is a hoax he
had the documents but he had the right
to because he Declassified them except
he says on the recording he didn't
declassify them but the documents were
planted and it's not a crime anyway and
also there were no documents why won't
you just accept that why is it you will
just insist on going after this guy the
biggest victim in the world the most
honest man in political history why
won't you accept the seven different
conflicting explanations about what he
did what he had and what he said and if
you think that this moment when he was
interviewed before or after the speech
was bad
you have to see the actual speech that
he gave
one of our sponsors is yada the Free
banking app that makes it fun to save
money just like a regular bank account
you can withdraw your money anytime and
it's fully FDIC insured when you keep
your money in a yada bank account you'll
have a shot at winning nightly cash
prizes ranging from two cents to a
million dollars for every twenty five
dollars in your account you get one
recurring ticket to the nightly prize
drawing so if you deposit a hundred
dollars you get four tickets every
single night without needing to make any
more deposits yada also offers some
great budgeting features the possibility
of early paydays a debit card that
rewards you with up to one hundred
percent cash back and tickets on every
purchase yata members have already won
over 15 million dollars so say goodbye
to the traditional savings account with
the minimal interest rate Freakonomics
have described prize linked savings
accounts like a no lose Lottery download
the app now start saving for a chance to
win big with yada the app where savings
meets excitement go to with yada.com
Pacman the link is in the description